all right many of us will be getting out
of the house this summer and enjoying
the great outdoors of course and with
lake mead in our own backyard
you don't have to go too far jc is
showing us more
last season on the lake we went
wakeboarding we went jet skiing we
explored
secret coves and today we're going
fishing hey bruce hey j.c how you doing
got your rod for you
a child's rod this is perfect no problem
what kind of uh what kind of boat was
going on
so last time we took out that 400 halite
yes today we're gonna upgrade a little
bit we're gonna take a 1985 boston
whaler what
that that's absolutely perfect this is
gonna be an amazing day
so when this boat came off the factory
line ronald reagan was the president he
was but there's
a cool backstory on it though huh yeah
so we're we're actually a boston whaler
dealer this is a 1985 boston whaler
originally was sold as a fishing boat to
a fishing guide
and it's now a work boat for us but we
were the very first boston wheeler
dealer my
grandparents were in 1958 or 59
on the west coast
[Music]
we made it las vegas bay now now bruce
this is i was inside your bait shop and
this one
this this lower color for lower caught
my eye if it caught your eyes it's gonna
catch fish's eyes
exactly so can we put that one on on
this this rod here let's do it let me
grab it and grab your finger
perfect i read something that fish they
actually can they can smell stuff yeah
is the fact that our
our hands and our scent is now all over
that lower that might um
we rubbed our hands and anchovies to
start so that's the trick
and there's the switch right yeah so
flip the switch
here bring it back to you and then if
you hold your finger just like you got
it yeah
and then open it up oh that's the gopro
in the water
i'll go in and get it this is the life
[Music]
fishing the lake
when it comes to speed does it matter i
think you come in real slow and just
lure that fish in
no pun intended i think the fish are
laughing actually drop the gopro in the
water probably
i was looking online doing some research
okay and it said when it comes to
fishing
las vegas bay which is where we are
prime time is like four
five six o'clock in the morning yeah
yeah yeah we're like uh
four or five o'clock at night yeah based
on the sun this is this is high noon
right now
yeah it's not looking good yeah
don't lose bearing on our gopro now does
the engine scare the fish
absolutely if you're watching right now
the trick is to take note as to what
bruce and i are doing and do the
complete opposition opposite
you roll up i'm screaming i don't know
why scaring all the fish
oh yeah it's on now this this is a
classic shakespeare fishing rod this is
actually i had a shakespeare's again
yeah yeah
this is the spider-man version here we
go this one's very simple
push the button hold the button
look at that throw and there you go
that's it look at that right there oh
look
bruce caught something yeah we need a
stick for dinner tonight
it's operation rescue gopro time
do you have a net or anything no
we're not real fishermen
[Music]
let's recap photographer lance broke his
headphones we lost a gopro in the lake
and bruce we didn't catch any fish but i
tell you what
it still was an amazing afternoon yeah
we had a great day but you know what we
appreciate having you down so we got
some fish and chips in the boathouse for
you here let's do it all right great
awesome is this uh work as a shirt
absolutely you're perfect come on in
too funny all right thank you so much jc
if you want to try your luck at fishing
or any other lake activities
just go to com boatinglakemead.com